ae
isto as suas shore vai falar agora vai e
eu queria dizer que o sexo é uma coisa
boa ou muito boa mas que nem toda a
gente sabe disso e eu estava pra começar
perguntar-se se toda a gente que está a
seis do sexo é uma coisa boa e quem acha
que eu devo ar
teoricamente é uma coisa boa né pergunta
outra coisa que como é que nós vivemos é
nossa sexualidade ou seja os fluídos
viver a nossa sexualidade e volta volver
perguntas sejam todos felizes com nossa
sexualidade
ok talvez tanque quando queremos dizer a
pergunta capciosa vida do especialista
não é porque que a etar flores com
sexualidade e fazer as perdas vezes
contra siqueira isso que não responderá
fui eu acho que as pessoas respondeu de
ver com o mundo quem está aflito só 60
influências o funcionário
eu acho que é preciso esquecer
quantidade infinda eu acho que qualquer
coisa que se faça intuitiva as portas e
um cinto vai e os cravos o de voar sua
independência a freqüência do que mesmo
uma vez por ar foi magnífico mais ou se
foram todos os dias e fiquem prontos é
isso ter enfim estas rapidinhas - um
site porque não podem vir o sexo a
qualidade do sexo pela quantidade do
orgasmo
não é uma situação também é uma forma de
viver a sexualidade mas é diferente
quero viver a minha motivação é um
sentimento que acompanhamos tributação
daquilo que é o sentimento que se vive
quando está com outra pessoa o que é
certo e essa pergunta vai surgir um
pedindo aquilo que eu tenho constatado
enfim todas as pessoas que chegou a mim
das perguntas daquela que o que minha
vida em consultórios tantos dilemas que
as pessoas têm e a maior parte das vezes
as questões delas tem a ver com esta é
uma certa felicidade vivência dessa da
sua própria sexualidade e que isso criar
causa do de vida todos nós causa da
nossa educação foi causa da forma como
cultural - fala sobre sexo por causa das
nossas vivências e o como sair hoje
confesso cozinha comentou o fato
determinado assunto ao longo do dia
conforme que não ia aparecendo e agora
eu também vou falar sobre isso na ótica
do decex folgada depois mudar do dia
enfim claramente não improvisar sobre o
tema original de ter ido escolar
mas uma das coisas que é importante a
gente pensa sobre o machucado num a
nossa própria vivência da sexualidade
como é que eu sei que é sexo
a esta área da sexologia e confesso que
fui pro castro e quando eu tinha de
escolher um sítio próprio dizia e fazia
nos traz o acadêmico fez o espírito
santo havia uma história km e 12
intermédio de uma conversa é um colega
que também escolheu essa via edson mauro
um congresso que eu tenho assistido
sobre sexo gera um fluxo incessante que
viu o lucro no hospital júlio de matos
os bispos se com a trip como
comportamento com a e comportamental e
que havia um núcleo falava estamos quer
a consulta de sexologia lisboa eo de
santos que engraçado eu também vou assim
está tudo certo aquelas pessoas que
pensam que eu escolhi de emergência esta
área
na altura até fazia teatro queria ser
atriz psicologia era é que torres que
ele a tudo o que os pais disseram ter um
curso e eu achei que o ciclo de aperto
responder mais as minhas dúvidas
enquanto pessoa e plantonista e escolhi
pra mim e depois agora mais tarde anos
mais tarde por ter escolhido também como
sempre preferindo o que é certo é que as
despesas da minha própria sexualidade e
difícil a pessoa apresente pensar nos
que e e minha vida enquanto luxemburgo
enquanto mina criar é uma criança foi
vivida num contraste com os pais é um
católico pai já morreu não é minha
família é católica e educação que o tivo
é católico eu fiz a primeira comunhão
cinema e nunca vi que sou católica
porque não me sinto católica porque
enfim instância mas o que é certo por
estranho que pareça e instituições há
instituições cada eo resto um pai-nosso
é uma coisa que é ao mesmo tempo ninguém
pode acreditar é a primeira vez que eu
liguei esta coisa deve ser para o
ambiente não é eu eu entrava num
programa que estava aflita que conseguiu
o que queria dizer e estar com o pai
nosso
aqui está o que é certo é que enfim a
vivência da sexualidade e da minha
família não era muito aberta como se
criarem uma maior parte das famílias
portanto é
hoje foram transmitidos sobre a própria
sexualidade ele residia e fez a
desinfecção de culpa não é no medo não
faz isto é estender os meninos têm mais
direto do que as meninas não é r acha a
perna não não punha sp na data os pais e
fai números em números aí e engraçado
que enquanto os meses de verão cinco
privilégio poder fazer uma série de
coisas nomeadamente desde pequeninos que
o biatlo de ensina masturbação nos puxa
por si para trás puxa a calcinha
petrachi eu sou um menino de maio pai
ajudou seu beber chope por cento para
trás e um deus ter revidado com sepse
aqui que isso tem um efeito magnífico
efe que é duro ficar ereto e potente
saque uma um relacionamento com o
próprio corpo muitas vezes os homens têm
que é diferente da forma como a mulher
viver sua sexualidade e e as
transformações que vão acontecer no seu
corpo e também suprir essas questões o
passageiro era reprimida é nível das
questões sexualidade tinha é que os
fantasmas como desaparecem
não é que os que acreditam que não é
capaz de tal forma num outro sentido de
ser feito não deve não deve ser
incentivar o sexo no casamento não é
motivação então está sem nunca se falou
enfim não não deve mudar pra
experimentar e as premissas que o aleph
teve aqui uma série de dados que uns vão
sendo capturados pelos pais pela família
e pelo cortar sua escola não é mesmo
quando não se fala fala muito não é
questão é que mesmo não viver mesmo em
conversas dentro estamos o flamengo
fomos é ligar a sexualidade por exemplo
e o que é certo é que não sei das
consultas do sai dos remédios que eu
recebo dos programas dos problemas
existe não só como aconteceu a mim
portanto tive que dar uma forma alterar
esta vive este molusco foram incutidos
desde desde pequenino é ter casa porque
grande parte da minha vida vivi neste
contexto é transformar isso em uma coisa
boa para mim
como é que a gente transforma é aquelas
coisas de que os dados numa conduta que
são supostamente negativos na vivência
da sexualidade uma coisa que passa
intuitiva e precisa a gente quer
é preciso não ter medo e claramente é
preciso pensar não tem direito de ser
feliz e viver sido minha própria
sexualidade e quando vejo os casais já
entraram naquele esquema os malucos em
que eu quero ter uma relação sexual com
ela não quer ela contou os dias eu já
passaram três dias que estão todos em
dia têm sexo com quatro dígitos a ser
vendidos no período
eu não gosto de saber que tanta coisa
está mais ou menos chapa e então me puxa
pronto dispõe porque não gosta de sexo
mesmo porque se minha vida conjugal fica
mais calma no ar disse nada e depois iam
também não fique grande não fiquei muito
satisfeito porque eu vou lá
ainda assim quase quando neco insuflado
por nonô não participe mas no meu
entender são limpas pai já cumpri minha
obrigação que tenta agora não tem chance
agulha mas foi uma mulher nestas
circunstâncias se pensarem sobre
sexualidade e clareamento diskin é uma
funcionalidade imensa
eu vi em que o chato que o homem da sua
vida não não vai não vai querer nada e
isto impressionante com tanta gente
entanto gerações sejam a enchentes sejam
elas é é ainda na entrada na urgência
seja um gesto de multas até mesmo homens
o duch enfim há uma idéia quase comcex
pessoa de ser uma coisa boa pra uma
coisa que é uma obrigação e toda a gente
sempre ouve falar disto os avós não é a
obrigação faz parte do pacote pronto tem
que ser é o sustento sem vencer e agora
sei já dessa forma de pensar mas pois na
realidade e mesmo as pessoas têm de ter
e tem mais informações ao poder falar
mais abertamente sobre sexo pois na sua
intimidade das vezes não acontece
o que acontece é que depois não são
capazes de mobilizar nada sobre o que
querem e que não querem nunca passou do
dia lugar sobre o que lhe vai na alma
quando estão com o outro e preferem
guardar preferem ter a cabeça dentro da
debaixo da terra feira que o tempo cura
e que o problema é que ela vivesse
negativa da sexualidade e com muitas
vezes quando vêm procurar ajuda já
possuem vencer muitos anos muitos anos
na vivência totalmente agradável e que
as pessoas não fizeram nada
porque acharam que nesta coisa não se
mexe e esta quer coisa mais natural do
mundo não é condenar água já não sei
falar muito porque estraga a
espontaneidade né
e depois porque quer dizer está se
instalando em horários paz é mais comum
haver alguma forma o que é certo é que a
pessoa tem que primeiro passe e perceber
exatamente e prender
neste centro desde o início desde a
infância que é possível falar sobre isso
sobre estas coisas é possível dizer o
que gosta é possível dizer o que não se
gosta e é possível construir a
intimidade na relação com o outro
muitas vezes começa não acho que temos
uma relação com o outro que fazer tudo
sexo anal sexo anal é tudo não é
mas tudo né mas depois eu ia direto na
china uma vivência da sexualidade é fish
e elas não gosto de sexo mas acha que
seu cartão de visita
prefiro que o homem que eu gosto pelo
que vem fazendo é tão bom que não vale a
pena mudar não é assim não é possível
mudar é possível toda a agenda deverá
ser divulgado com o presente
basta criado em baixo deixar ter medo e
deixarmos do dia achar que essas coisas
não são para ser faladas que essas
coisas não são para se dizer e cada vez
mais e e estes que dará por causa de
perguntar qual é o sonho não é qual é o
teu sonho e que as pessoas aqui não
tenho medo de ter um sexo bom e perceber
que têm direito a isso
nessa linha qualquer forma as televisões
não sei quem vou deslocar-me o projeto
grande de faquir do norte sul e as ilhas
falar nos vários sítios particularmente
junto que vivenciei fluir da sexualidade
não temos que viver o sexo não foi
conclusiva não temos que viver o sexo
com dor não é
não temos que ter um discurso defendendo
que os órgãos ou seja é socialmente
somos independentes
vivemos hoje é fizemos as coisas não é
estamos empreendedores construímos
empresas e depois quando chegamos a casa
na canção íntima queremos que nossa
parceria uma nora
eu adoro rock tivemos quando for mesmo
sim mas tecnicamente o orgasmo edifer
é ver que só um é a relação sexual em si
e temos também muitas vezes construíram
o que entendemos que vocês aqui uma
espécie de ditadura da forma como
devemos relacionar sexualmente sex é
coito e cyber nós temos antigos em que o
culto não é o sexo era a única função do
sexo era a procriação portanto é naquela
posição é daquela forma
espero que só consegue engravidar a
mulher e assim que é o sexo e ponto
final
passados tantos temos em 17 anos não é
visto como uma má fé única função como
reprodutiva
solano do prazer sexual mexe das
crianças que têm dos políticos vai eu
acho eu pergunto tem orgasmo e não hoje
como dizem eu não tenha gasto não tem
nome mas não uma forma não através de
distribuição time através do sexo oral
time mas eu não tenho agacha ou seja a
concessão sobre o sexo e quem desta
pessoa é uma constante diária e social
que o sexo é uma s room discursivamente
o coito e todos os outros comportamentos
sexuais são coisas que nós é quase uma
visão em que supostamente com as
piramidal é cônsul sexo fosse uma
espécie de mutirão diz em um bairro leva
8 um abraço leva o coach um sexo oral
leva oito discover estudos incompletos
não é ninguém esta ideia do que o órgão
só deve ser vivido no coito e uma coisa
tramada por quê porque a maior parte das
mulheres mais de 80% das mulheres
conseguem dirigir o organismo através do
tipo de emoção nomeadamente criada logo
se espera investir sempre o mesmo canal
que temos a fazer a minha parte das
minhas influências de amigos num que
interessa não é um pénis e eu digo não o
que interessa o homem windows por trás
diferente porque eu não sou velho
se eu não souber usar o resto ou seja os
maus mas já falamos aqui duas mãos que
tem tanto sensor judô vinhos não envolve
nada em férias mais o clítoris tem muito
mais dimensões nervosas que o próprio
glândula masculina do pênis e tem sua
mãe isso uma função é transexual é criar
duas relações homossexuais os meias têm
mais esta apreciação quando se toca uma
outra na do mundo rendimento nos casais
heterossexuais se não é utilizada uma
vez perguntaram assim disposto
eu já passei para fazer a interação
ainda tem que ir lá com o mal não dá
isso não é suposto qualquer posição da
poule mão
não há nenhuma que não dê a polícia não
é trivial dizer que ficavam felizes
porque durante a relação sexual ela
tinha se masturbado e o pássaro
sentir-se ofendido por isto que começa
de fato não quer mais sexo
na época temos que encontrar sua forma
de chegar à e os mecanismos de chegar à
felicidade sexual também família e
muitas vezes em frente àquela forma
entre os 188 é o que menos interessa que
ele há uma relação sexual com uma mulher
normal se não houver línguas nove outras
formas de distribuição não há nada feito
e muitas vezes não têm souto pose tudo
ter uma duração curta ao propor que
aconteça uma certa tirania que debateu
já naquele dia que saiu já cumpri la
mas eu tenho uma descida um baixíssimo o
braço e eu já enviei de fazer isso
porque eu saio mais quero um baixo o
tipo vai me faltar para cima
e ele perdeu baixos que após tira a
afagar o kalmar um beijo o filho nem
sempre compensa
eu faço isso evite começa a ter uma
série de comportamentos de digitação que
tem a ver com a transmissão do jogo
carinho o afeto é que porque só de
pensar que você tem que ir o castigo mas
vai ficar parada e as tarifas são mudas
quando o casal observa que o sexo não
pode ser uma forma piramidal mas sim
como uma paleta de um pintor e poeta do
pintor tem o rafael tem um governo tem o
sul com o encarnado eo pintor nos umas
vezes vendo outras vezes amarelo outras
vias de encarnados boa eo tubo e
mandou-a rápido e qualquer discurso está
exatamente a mesma qualidade ou seja
qualquer comportamento sexual diz que
seja bem-vindo facto com garra tem a
mesma validade não precisa ser sempre o
mesmo é sempre com 85 visão sobre as
julgar forma harmoniosa mais vezes no
meo
outras vezes o encarnados outras vezes o
ver mais uma coisa o jovem filho
o que é certo é que seria com que as
pessoas tivessem muito mais dispostas
por um momento de intimidade e não tem
tempo pra falar mais sobre o discurso
intitulado rock ao rap que vencer
[Aplausos]